sean salisbury morning host of the sean
salisbury show on sports talk 790 in
houston the former nfl quarterback
kind enough to join us all right sean
should they
consider trading him yeah well first off
dan i got a voice like fergie and jesus
okay let's look
and i don't have a flannel shirt it's
good to be on i think they should dan
here's what i think fan bases and people
need to get over
is that loyalty thing right oh my gosh
we
can't let the guy who is fabulous in the
community three-time defensive player of
the year
but then you start to say because i can
promise you in houston considering what
bill o'brien left the franchise
assets wise and the way they're paying
them and they're one in six because they
are who they are
jj's never winning a super bowl here and
he's 31
and with the injury background now he is
still a hell of a player the problem is
every year that goes by the value starts
to diminish
so if you're a team like let's say
pittsburgh seattle went got dunlap or
the 49ers without bose and you say we're
close
we're a player or two away and
especially in a league that doesn't play
much defense j.j watt can help
so what do you get you're desperate
maybe you give up a second rounder
you're never going to get a first but
dan next year it's going to be a fourth
rounder or a fifth round we just don't
give assets away so
i would the texans are going to have to
rebuild they're going to get rid of a
lot of these guys in the offseason
they're trying to find a general manager
and a coach
i would do it as hard as it is for
people to say oh my gosh
jj this you can't do that when jj
retires and goes into the hall of fame
he'll come back at texan right
you can and you should this team has no
assets no draft picks
uh in the first couple rounds it's time
and jj watt
outside of deshaun watson and tunsil
you're not trading is your biggest value
or maybe will fuller it has to happen
but i don't think it's going to dan
why because they're afraid to death of
that the owner first of all is not
heavily involved i don't think
jack easterby really i mean really wants
to be involved and by the time
the deadline is going to pass by the
time a general manager and head coach
are
and i think they're so pr conscious
about it and their loyalty
that i think the pr hit for them they
think would be too big
the truth of the matter is if they want
to do the right thing most fans in this
town once they got over the initial
shock would say
it's about time and if you could milk a
second rounder i don't think they have
to end
there may be some buzz nationally but
you know there is minimal if no buzz
here
locally i've tried to create some it
ain't working very good i promise you
yeah i just look at this and say
you know we're not going anywhere what
if jj
quietly privately said look if you want
to trade me
don't you don't have fans in the stands
sean so the hit you're going to take
is not going to be seen it's not a
visual they're not showing up for
football games here
maybe the local ratings might not be
great but if if i'm the texans i got to
start thinking
the next five years not next week or the
next year and i think will fuller if
green bay is willing to give you
anything for him
thank you will some nice parting gifts
absolutely
dan i'm 100 with you one hundred percent
because
you look at this you gotta you know
everybody begs for a franchise
quarterback right
you got him but you're going to waste
him because no matter and
he's one of the top you know he's
putting up yards and average yards per
attempt look what it's getting them
they beat jacksonville now look at the
other side even with j.j watt out there
as bill belichick always said i could
take your best player away on defense so
what are they doing
you double him they couldn't stop me you
or katie high school on a friday night
from running the ball against them
so if that's the case let's start to get
assets and rebuild and learn now you've
got a franchise quarterback
and i'm with you somebody will fuller is
going to ask for a lot of money next
year dan
and they're already so invested
money-wise at the wide receiver position
and they're one and six i can find
rookies to go one in six
he's gonna want what 15 16 17 million
dollars
no go get an asset trade him for a
second or a third round pick
and keep it moving son we got to move on
and if you want to build a franchise
there's no reason to wait because this
team
i i can't even visualize where they're
going in the next three or four years
with no assets
i know one thing i got a left tackle and
a quarterback that ain't doing me any
good i can i can win one game with me at
quarterback but i also wonder
if i'm eric b enemy the offensive
coordinator with the chiefs who's got
he's going to have an opportunity to
take his pick probably
let's say the jets are open i don't know
if jacksonville is going to be open
uh atlanta's open the texans is oh
you know that situation's open if i'm
eric the enemy
you start to look at the inventory you
have here with what's the future what's
my salary cap what kind of draft picks
who do i have i don't know if eric
bienemy goes boy
texans that's the place i want to go
yeah and then you start to look at
atlanta too right
dan i mean that's a situation you're
exactly right the one thing that drives
you to the texans is
the number number four right you say
number four then you say well
the front office how committed are they
what's the general manager what's his
longevity
jets or jacksonville i may have trevor
lawrence and i'd rather have trevor
lawrence
than deshawn watson as dan i i posed a
question yesterday on my show
would you trade trevor lawrence straight
up for deshaun watson
the jets wouldn't the texans should
right
but it's not going to happen that's a
foregone conclusion so yeah
if i'm eric b enemy while it seems like
well the best quarterback of all the
guys you named is deshawn watson
but if you go to the jets it's a team
there's no expectations right off the
bat you go get trevor lawrence and maybe
trevor lawrence makes that a
free agent destination as well and you
have far more assets
and he's a generational type player
watson maybe as well but i'm with you
i don't think it's the lead dog anymore
considering the situation here
although the enemy's going to get a job
i'm not sure that houston will be the
first one on the list
now ishaan salisbury you can hear him on
sports talk 790 in houston the sean
solsbury show
while we're talking about trading iconic
figures here would the rockets
consider trading james harden i don't
think they could trade russell westbrook
but would they consider trading james
harden
been a huge topic now with steven silas
named the head coach dan on my show this
morning
of why not if you're gonna go and just
get there
right because they're not winning an nba
title with the with the roster how it's
constructed and
the small ball and they don't have think
about the lack of draft picks the astros
with the
with the the problems with the the the
steins sign stealing
the rockets who have gotten rid of all
they don't have any assets coming in and
the
texans dan we ain't got a draft pick
until 2040
okay grandkids are going to be playing
by then so
um they won't dan he's got more powers i
think james loves being powerful
and he is powerful in this organization
and once he walks out the door what
assets you're going to get for him that
are going to help you win
to get get to a championship because he
goes out his value is not gonna get what
you what four first-round picks where
they gonna be picked
is it the knicks who's he going to and
they love him here and you say well are
you going to get an offensive player
would nobody trade it's like
quarterbacks rarely do you trade a
superstar that can score for you
and whether it's teams coming here or
james going out he's not going anywhere
right now either even with daryl mori
out of the building and on his way to
philly
and a new head coach coming in they're
going to build it around
james harden they're going to win 50
games they're going to get to the
playoffs and they're going to be
eliminated
i would consider it because if you're
going to rebuild let's go now
but with that salary and with the love
of this city and his offensive
performance
james harden is not going anywhere
although that's another one that they
should consider
great to talk to you as always shawn you
got a couple of topics there to
dive into on your show certainly yep
absolutely why are you smirking i got a
lot
i'm not i'm not smirking i i am i am
going to dive into all of them but thank
you it's great to be on your show
now i'm always appreciative now
there you go i appreciate it dan thank
you thank you buddy that's sean
salsberry morning host of the sean
salisbury show in sports 790 houston
former nfl quarterback